in the last video we proved the angle
addition formula for sine so you could
imagine in this video I would like to
prove the angle addition for cosine or
in particular that the cosine of X plus
y of X plus y is equal to the cosine of
X cosine of X cosine of Y cosine of Y
minus so if we have a plus here we're
going to have a minus here minus sine of
X sine of X sine of Y and I'm going to
use a very similar technique to the way
I proved it for sine and so I encourage
you to pause the video either now or at
any time that you get the inspiration to
see if you can do this proof on your own
so just like we thought about it for
sine what is the cosine of X plus y in
this diagram right over here well X plus
y is this angle right over here and if
we look at the right triangle a d f
cosine of X plus y well cosine is
adjacent over hypotenuse segment AF over
the hypotenuse or since the hypotenuse
is just one a F divided by one it's
going to be AF so cosine of X plus y is
just the length of segment it's just the
length of segment AF so that right over
there is equivalent to this right over
here let me actually write that down so
copy and paste so this length of segment
AF is cosine of X plus y so let's think
about how we can get that and the way
I'm going to think about it is given the
other right triangles we have in this
diagram if we could figure out that or
AF let me write it this way this thing
which is the same thing as AF is equal
to let me write it this way it's equal
to the length of segment a-b so it's
equal to the length of segment a-b which
is this entire segment right over here
minus the length of segment FB so minus
this segment all right over here minus
the length of segment FB and just from
the way our angle addition formula looks
for cosine you might guess what
going to be a B and what's going to be
FB if we can prove that a B is equal to
this and if we can prove that FB is
equal to this then we're done because we
know that cosine of X plus y which is AF
is equal to a B minus FB or if we can
prove if we can prove this that it's
equal to that minus that so let's think
about what these things actually are
what is a B so let's look at right
triangle ACB we know from the previous
video that it since ad has a high pot or
since triangle ADC has AI potenuse of 1
this length is 1 that AC is cosine of X
and so what is a B well think about it a
B is adjacent to angle the angle that
has measure Y or we could say that the
cosine let me do it down here
we could say since I've already looked
at all of that we could say that the
cosine of Y cosine of Y is equal to its
adjacent side the length of its adjacent
side so that is segment a B over the
hypotenuse over cosine of X cosine of X
or multiply both sides by cosine of X we
get that a B segment a B is equal to
cosine of X cosine of X times cosine of
Y cosine of Y this isn't which is
exactly what we set out to prove we've
just proved proven that a B is indeed
the length of segment a B is indeed
equal to cosine X cosine Y this whole
thing is equal to cosine X cosine Y so
now we just have to prove that segment
FB is equal to sine X sine Y well this
looks like a bit of a strange segment
right over here it's not part of any at
least right triangle where we know that
I've drawn where we know one of the
angles but we can see from this diagram
EC bf is a rectangle we use that fact in
the proof for the angle addition formula
for sine we'll also use it now because
that tells us that FB is the same as EC
is EC and what is EC going to be equal
to well we have this angle Y right over
here and so what is what is what is
let's let's see this side is opposite
the angle Y so we might want to involve
sine so we know that sine of Y sine of Y
I'm looking right over here is equal to
the length of the opposite side which is
the length of EC which is the length of
EC over the hypotenuse which is sine of
X sine of X we figured that out from the
last video if this is X opposite over
hypotenuse is sine of X well the
opposite is just 1 so the opposite is
equal to sine of X but over here
multiply both sides by sine of X and we
get what we were looking for EC is equal
to sine of X sine of X times sine of Y
times sine of Y and once again EC was
the exact same thing has the same length
as segment FB so we have just shown that
segment FB is equal to sine of X times
sine of Y this is equal to that right
over there so once again cosine of X
plus y which is equal to segment AF is
equal to segment a-b minus the length of
segment a-b minus the length of segment
FB which is equal to we've proven the
length of segment a-b is cosine X cosine
Y minus the length of segment FB which
is sine of X sine of Y and we are done